上一期同学问我们的问题
那我而且很多知识都是新鲜出炉
哎反正就是各种的这个这个情况百出
待会儿给大家讲
那我现在呢先给大家讲一下
我们这一期要讲的内容
去那个大家说我的脸都肿了
还准备这篇那个这这次这个talk对吧
然后我们就在中秋节对着月光
我们去讲一下lumen对吧
其实讲论我觉得讲的不过瘾
我们要把整个全局光照给大家讲一讲
那首先的话呢诶我这不是我的第一
不好意思了
果然已经偷一局晕了
首先的话呢
第一个就是我们的课程组
给大家讲一些有意思的好消息
我们课程组准备了一些小卡片
然后呢
我们会在小卡片里面给同学们写一些
我们的祝福的话
然后呢
以后大家如果能收到我们课程组的
这个那个t恤衫呐或者什么小礼物的时候
我们也会附送这个小卡片给大家
所有拿到这个卡片的
就是我们games 4104课程的口号是什么
人均一个自研引擎
所以的话呢我觉得所有想做
想探索自研引擎的小伙伴
都是勇气和智慧的化身
所以的话呢我们也想用这个小卡片一起
共勉一下我们这个社区
你的这个每一个人确实我们很需要鼓励啊
到现在为止的话
我们在行业里还被称为是异类好
那就所以呢这是我们课程组的一种
大家精神共鸣的表达
那么另外一个的话呢
就是告诉大家一个好消息
我们的pico引擎的话呢终于上新了
我们刚刚实现了一个小小的gpu particle
然后就是觉得好玩
其实也没有什么特别的意思
就是说啊就是你看上面一个问号
我们的party落下来之后
地上会形成这样的一个pattern
这个其其其其其实呢是一个怎么说呢
你可以认为叫屠龙之技吧
就是说在现代的这个3a游戏里面的话
这是个蛮常用的一个基础系统
但是的话呢
就是如果作为一个就是休闲游戏的话
一般不会用到这么复杂的功能
但是我们就是觉得很好玩对吧
也让大家看一看
就是其实引擎这东西没有那么神秘
就什么高端的算法啊
其实你都可以实现的
所以啊这个东西的话
我们好像已经check in到
我们的那个github上了
大家可以上面可以下载
那这个我我个人觉得还蛮好玩的
等我们的课程上完之后的话呢
我们会尽可能的就是抽时间
跟同学们去讲一讲皮克的引擎的代码解读
就是欢迎大家关注我们的微信公众号
这样的话我们拉了一个微信的小社区
这样大家可以就在社区里面可以去讨论
然后后面时间允许的话呢
我这边也在想当然
我得我得我得说服我们课程组的小伙伴
大家已经累得都不行了
然后如果我们还有一点残残留的力气的话
我们就那个持续的给那个pico里面
注入一些有趣的代码
其实我个人还觉得挺好玩的
因为我自己在做自己引擎的时候
觉得哎呀那个代码太大了
维护起来太难了对吧
当然pico的话呢我就觉得很很简单
很轻便
可以很easily的加入各种各样
我们想要的feature
所以的话希望那个整个pico
变成我们大家的一个playground
大家一起去享受这个过程
而且呢现在课程组check的东西多一点吧
到后面的话
我是希望我们社区里的小伙伴
我们一起来check in
这样的话我们把这东西越做越好玩
反正就是个开源社区好
然后第三个的话呢就是我必须得highlight一下
我们的同学们实在是太有才了
就是我们改作业改到了越来越怎么说呢
就是呃应该来讲的话
就是说作为一个就是真的很有意思
就是说作为一个其实还没有怎么功能搭完
的一个开源小引擎的话
大家已经开始很快的把它变得越来越像个
专业的游戏引擎了
就是大家你像这种材质的调整啊对吧
这个做的还是很酷吧
这个已经有点像那个
就是专业的游戏引擎的样子了
然后呢
我觉得很酷啊
这个后面如果大家需要什么工具的话
千万不要不好意思
直接来问我们课程组
说不定我们做着做着就把皮克我做了一个
真的能做成一个商业游戏引擎的
这样的一个商业游戏的这样一个小引擎
反正无所谓
只是开源引擎
大家随便用
所以啊我觉得挺好的
就是说实话讲了快有大半年的课程了
然后看到这些东西的时候
还是蛮有成就感的
觉得嗯
我这这大半年我们同学们没有一起很辛苦
然后呢最后一个就是说啊
本来我们今天准备了三个社区问答的问
题的问题
但是呢我后面时间实在来不及了
就是准备这些问题怎么回答
我说这边我先狗头保命对吧
我先挖一个坑
就是下一次下一次讲none night的时候呃
我争取这个把一回答那个社区两波问题
就这这次这一波和下一次的这一波
这样的话呢这个实在才能回得上来
然后最后告诉大家一个这个有趣的消息
就是啊
马上因为我们上次说
我们哎我们又是职业的这个歌王
本来说这个30万播放量的时候呢
我们会做一个彩蛋视频
但是呢我们就割啊割啊割割
一直割到现在已经快五上播完了
谢谢大同学们对我们的支持啊
真的没有想到
就是我们会播放量会有这么大
那我们呢就做了一个就是这个彩蛋视频
这个视频还蛮有意思的
大家明天那个敬请期待对吧
有可能你们想看到的一些小伙伴
还有一些你想看到的一些有趣的东西啊
会在那个彩蛋视频里看到
那就留留了一个小小的惊喜
留给明天
那我们就言归正传
就讲我们今天的课程主题内容啊
就是动态的全局光照和lumen啊
对这个lumen对吧
这个大名鼎鼎
但是为什么我们备课背背到最后已经背的
就是我觉得就是属于这种不断的跑题
就是这个就是我们也是跑题小王子
就是本来准备个len
但是我们却突然决定想跟大家讲g i了
确实是呃
我大概记得是准备到上个周五的时候吧
上个周五晚上我就说哎呀
我我我要把lman讲清楚
我如果不把以前的那个ji讲一遍的话
好像陆妹是讲不清楚的
因为如果大家不去讲那个g i的话呢
大家看到rom里面的东西
那个技术细节就是无比的多
然后呢大家也不知道这个细节
感觉从天上掉下来的
其实它因为你们的很多算法
很多思想
在之前的一些gi的那个方法里面
都会出现过
所以它很像一个算法的集大成者
然后索性就一不做二不休
我就说算了吧
我们就这节课擅自未经大家的那个许可
我们就擅自修改了主题对吧
我们把那个决定把那个什么pgc啊
把那个就是那个啊还有什么啊
match making那个the motion match啊
这些东西我们把它先放在一边
这个大不了我们看二零系列的课程
给大家补上什么地方
又挖了一个更大的坑
我们一零还没讲完呢
我们就开始讲二零系列的这个坑了
那么我们呢就是在一零系列
最后两节课的话
我们就放飞自我
就讲两个核心技术
一个讲lumen
一个讲null
那么如果lumen采取这种
叫做把它历史渊源的讲清楚
我们在讲这个算法的话
nana的大概率也可能是不只是讲nana
可能把这种class base的rendering啊
这种新的这个visibility buffer match
这种新的mesh apply啊
也可能也会跟大家去提一下
所以的话呢
我们是第一次这么任性的去准备一节课
但是呢任性归任性啊
工作量其实非常的大
而且呢说实话呃卫生这节课准备到最后的
几乎是到最后的
我想想啊
对上课之前最后两分钟截稿
然后我们十分钟预热就开始上线了
真的是新鲜出炉
这里面的很多知识点是我刚刚确认过
可能不到15分钟
那为什么会这样呢
因为真的是细节特别多
很多时候我们被迫要扒开源码去看源码
所以呢我不能讲这节课是在给大家讲课
更像的是什么呢
就是王鑫师兄带着大家一起做paper reading
我不知道大家以前有没有
在高校里面参加过这种科研组啊
就科研组以前有个活动
就是说
我们比如说会把今年或者某个系列的文章
同学们分头
然后呢我们一起做paper reading
大家读完文章跟大家去讲
那么preparing的特点是什么呢
就是说其实我也是新学的
我也是心理解的
但是呢我愿意用我的眼睛
用我的脑子先把它消化一遍
然后再和大家分享
这样的话降低大家去理解这部分的工作量
所以papi的特点是什么
有些东西讲的可能不一定正确
但没关系
我在尽我最大的可能性去讲这个东西
那么今天这节课呢第二个特点呢就是说啊
其实lumen的话
实际上无论是咱们虚幻自己啊
还有很多优秀的同学都做过一些分享
可能我们讲的结构会跟船长
那个常规的结构不太一样
我们更多的是从全局光照的思路
然后呢把它的算法重新组织了一遍
就是我想尝试一下
就这样讲
是不是更容易让大家
就是说跳过那些非常非常琐碎的细节
而更多的去理解它整个算法的整体结构
其实我为什么一上来会先讲那个gi的话
其实也是出于这个思路
也就是说你去理解gi最宏观的结构
你才能理解lin是怎么产生的
那你基于机关机y的这个基础的
方法论的话
其实你就能理解
如果有那么多算法
它到底分成几大块
这也是我们今天这节课
我想尝试的一个方法
因为确实这个我觉得既然开讲了
我觉得还是希望大家讲的能明白吧
而且这是我们是一零系列的课程对吧
很多同学以前的基础可能还是需要补充的
那我这时候正好把基础给大家补一下
但好那就废话不多说了
首先讲global nomination对吧
那这节课首先的话呢
我要把我的祖师爷再抬出来一下
对不对
这个render equation
我记得我在第五讲的时候讲的rendering的
第一节课的时候
我就讲过
recreation
简直是这个hello
也不叫也不叫害
我们不能说应该就应该是指导我们了
整整这个多少年了
已经35年了对吧
确实30 30 35年以上了
那么确实是这
这也是反映了这个科学家的了不起啊
就是它可以放在mental类的
把一些物理现象的本质
用这么简单的数学语言表达出来
那我们今天做的几乎所有的rendering的工作
都在去满足这个render equation对吧
这就像爱因斯坦说出e等于mc平方好
大家都很开心
讲清楚了
但是你真的把原子弹造出来
你会发现这个后面的挑战
技术的工程的各种问题就是让你难如登天
所以我们会用曼哈顿工程工程
但是最终原子弹是炸出来了对吧
但是这个这个就是我们的render increation的话
到现在为止啊
这个核弹还是没有爆炸
因为其实直到今天
我们并没有任何的一款游戏引擎
能够做到实时的fly render equation来做
这个真的是非常非常难
但是我们现在在做什么呢
我们在无限的逼近这件事
我们在一步一步的逼近它
而今天为什么给大家这么着重的去讲一下
lumen
我个人认为就是说
它代表了我们在一个关键领域
就是gi这个领域正在这个非常明显的
这是一个significant mstone
就是一个非常重要的一个mstone
我们在逼近这件事
ok那这件事情为什么这么难呢
它其实最核心的点就是说直线光照
当一个光源照向你的时候
那就是个点点光照着你
那是比较简单的
但是g i的意思就是说你四面八方来的光
和我表面的b r d方程要进行积分
最后能形成我的这个最宏光的光照
这个里面这个复杂的积分过程
其实是非常麻烦的
因为大家想想在现在计算机里面
对于屏幕上将近十个变量的pixel对吧
如果你是8k
你如果那就会更高
那么这个时候每一个像素
每个点
我要去采集四面八方的各种各样的
这个这个这个射过来的光线
算出来的值
这个计算量有多大
那这个想想大家想想是不是很吓人
那么更复杂的是什么呢
就是这个光从什么地方来对吧
他不是说诶我在四面八方摆了无数个灯
其实灯在哪里
灯是无限多的
就是说为什么呢
因为当一个你只在这个场景里面
你只放了一个光源
但这一个光源它可以把周围的无数个
就是物体的无数个叫小面片全部照亮
那每一个被照亮的小面片
它就是一个光源来照亮你
那同时呢这些小面片照亮其他的地方
它会再反弹回来
又会形成新的光源
那么你如果是一次反弹
就是single bus对吧
如果多次反弹就是multibs
这个我记得在前面讲range的时候
给大家讲过这件事情
那么这样的一个case的话
实际上对random来讲就是极为复杂的
大家想想这个数学上就很复杂
那么最著名的这个g i的一个案例是什么
就是我们的右手边这张图叫什么
canair box对吧
这是大名鼎鼎的kair box
大家想想多简单
一个正方形的q
左边是那个红色
右边是绿色
上面放了一个光源
注意啊
这个光源它不是点光源
它是一个面光源
光源本身你可以把它分解成无限度
然后下面就放一个长条
那个长方块
一个一个方形块
哎
就这一个conor box
实际上你想把它做的跟光猝死一样
就会真的是难以非常的非常的难
然后如果这东西还要real time
你就更痛苦
那么这里面为什么这个光学现象
大家仔细看什么复杂
你看到没有
这边光射到那边红色的墙反弹回来
就会有很多红光
红光就会照亮这个那边那个长方块的
那个那个那个就是它的左侧面对吧
同样的你看到又靠右边的墙上
也看到绿色的这个这个这个light leaking嘛
就是这种光color的leaking
那么这样的一种很复杂的光影效果
其实就是这个gi的效果
而gi的效果的话呢
在真实的游戏场景里面会更复杂
那为什么gi这么重要呢
因为我们这以游戏为例
如果游戏它只能处理deoliking的话
比如说以一个这个这个博物馆为例的话
那你看到的环境就是这样了
那为什么我们的游戏你看的不是这样的
因为我们还会加上一些hack
我记得我在讲专顿时
我就讲过一个最简单的hack叫什么呢
叫那个啊
就叫ambion light对吧
环境光
那其实这个对gi的一个hack
但是那个效果其实很一般
而真正的积压的话
它的效果是非常丰富和复杂的
而对于现代游戏来讲的话
就是我们很多时候
比如说诶一个一个岩洞
我给他打个洞对吧
围着一个房间打开窗子
你看到光射进了
拉开窗帘
对不对
或者说在一个昏暗的晚上
几个人打着手电对吧等等
各种复杂的这种光学现象
其实都需要在游戏中模拟
当然这也是我们
现在rendering已经进入了一个恐怖谷
就是说过去我们可以一眼看出来说诶
这是计算机生成的画面对吧
比如说我们在玩super maria的时代
我们不会要求他画的很真实
你只要那个maria做得足够可爱就完事儿了
对不对
至少在过去10年以前
游戏里的画面我们还不敢
这个基于说我们逼近于真实
但是现代的商业游戏的话
其实已经越来越逼近于
就是至少是达到一个动画片的这种质量
其实已经跟动画片质量差不多了吧
已经逼近了
然后呢我们还要逼近什么的
其实现在很多游戏的
如果你看他的过场动画的话
其实非常像手持相机拍出来的
这种纪实电影
所以说在未来10年的话
就是我们rendering的核心的挑战其实之一吧
只能说之一其实是gi
因为你不上gi的话
它的整个画面看上去就是塑料的
就是这个cg的呃
呃不要黑cg啊
cg也是很了不起的
就是就是说我们那个游戏的这种画面
但是呢你上了g i之后
如果你再加上pp r材质对吧
再加上那个就是更丰富的几何细节
确实现在游戏引擎所说出来的东西
有的时候能达到以假乱真了
就大家可能如果看一下
有些现代的一些东西释放出来的话
确实是很震撼
所以整个return rendering行业
游戏行业
我们已经在非常非常逼近那个恐怖谷
而这个恐股到底有多少年
我们才能爬得出来的话
那就要看我我背的是造化了
所以这也是今天我们讲这节课的重点
就是也是鼓舞大家
更多人冲上去去解决这个问题
那么其实呢这个就是gation
最复杂的问题是什么呢
就是积分就是你对光各种各样的积分对吧
那么积分怎么办
哎这里面就有一个大名鼎鼎的蒙特卡罗
integration
蒙特卡罗积分对吧
他的想法其实非常简单
就是对一个函数对吧
你就是从a到b
那么你假设是一段的
比如说我做rendering的时候
不就是在一个半球上进行积分嘛
好嘛我怎么办
我对你进行采样嘛
我加了50个点
哒哒哒哒哒对吧
我把你的每个点踩完之后加在一起诶
平均一下啊
这应该加在一起对吧
some of the area
然后呢我就能知道你的这个光的多多少
对于cd来讲
不就是把所有的方向的这个光全部给
那个他的设定的每一个那个radiance
全部算出来
加在一起
就是我最后的样子嘛对吧
这就是这就是蒙特卡洛积分的一个方法
那这个方法呢
其实是我们过去可以说是差不多啊
这几十年吧大家在做gi的话
一般的方法
因为其实从这个quation提出来
就是过去的几十年
我们的图形学行业真的是前赴后继啊
就是在解决这个全局光照的问题
这个问题真的是很痛苦很痛苦
那么其实呢我们就有大名鼎的motor
color retracing对吧
这个方法其实呢思想非常的简单
就是我从眼睛的地方
对于屏幕上每个像素对吧
我就可以射中一个物体
这个物体的话呢我就往它四面八方去投射
这个瑞什么意思
就是找这些方向
有没有那个射来的这个光光光
然后呢这光呢射出去又打中物体
其他的方面在那个点呢
他又踩四面八方去问
然后呢这样的话你就看到什么一次半死
两次半次三次bs
大家发现没有
它的计算复杂度是怎么上去的
我相信聪明的同学
可能马上就能感觉出来了
这就是一个指数级的扩张啊
对不对
所以说做single box的话还可以
我勉强能忍对吧
但是我要做multi bounce的话
四次bx
那基本上就是要死人的对吧
而且呢
这里面还有一个很有趣的一个点是什么呢
就这里面这张图还没有讲清楚啊
实际上在场景里面
他的那个真正亮的地方
像康奈尔box这种整体基本照亮的case
实际上是很特殊的
在很多场景里面
比如说一个硕大无比的房间
它真正亮的地方
可能就是天顶的窗子那一点
但是你整个房间就是被这个multi bounce的
这个光照亮了
这个时候你在进行三零的时候
你会经常发现一件什么事情呢
比如设设了啊50根锐
但是只有极少数的锐
所以他根本没踩到光
唉这个事情真的是会发生的
所以说这种蒙特卡罗吹醒在过去的几十年
他的一生之敌是什么呢
哎就是采样
如果采样不好
你就会发现我因为是随机的嘛
对不对
所以我没有办法保证
我的pixel a和pixel b形成的这个采样的结果
它在结果是连续的
我们就会产生大量的noise
对这个你想想看
就是过去我们就算用那个就是cg p u对吧
一帧渲染几个小时
其实我们为什么要选那么慢
就是大家如果听说过
以前做动画电影的成本为什么特别高对吧
一帧可以炫一个小时
大家想多恐怖
而且还是一个那个还是一个farm
就是一个render fm
就渲染农场
它就是这个原因
就是因为你要做这种蒙特卡洛retracing啊
这简直是丧心病狂啊
对然后呢
所以呢这个里面最痛苦的事情是什么
就是sampling
就是说这这个概念的同学们
一定要建立起来
因为你去理解啊
这个lumen的所有的他的技术上
用的各种各样的hack
它的hack实在太多了
但是呢它核心解决的这个问题啊
其实就是怎么更好的300的问题对吧
怎么有效的去分布这些3伏林的问题
那么好三零就是重要的k了
因为你会发现
比如对于蒙
基于蒙特卡罗贝斯的这种方法的话
一般来讲你的三炮里数量越多一定是越好
但是呢你不是越越多的话
系统的消耗会不会越大
它就会越慢对吧
这里面给了个例子
就是比如说像这里面做一个蒙卡reacing
如果只有一根瑞
就是我们的左上角那个的话
你可以看到很明显的noise
然后呢它每一张图呢大概是从左到右
从上到下都是double一下的对吧
那你到后面那个就是已经二的16次方
26次方多少
就是每一个点要射出去
大概64000根瑞的时候诶
你看着已经很smooth了对吧
但是这如果是single bs
我觉得几分钟你也许能选得出来
但是如果是multi bs的话
我反正已经不知道需要多久才能
算得出来了
所以说其实如何
三零是这种所有的蒙特卡罗贝斯的这种gi
犯法的一个核心点
那三怎么做呢
那最简单的方法是什么
这个呢其实是最好的一个一个方法对吧
一个一个一个最传统的一个方法
但是呢其实如果你的信号
哎你这样的三里呢
他除非密度很高
否则的话呢
它可能是对采样率并不是有效的利用
比如说我想三破一个
在一个空间上的一个广场对吧
对我的光照积分
那我如果这个窗只有一个窗子
它是有量的
你在你采用的两根锐中间的夹
夹在这个空间的话
如果飞出10米之外
他那个采样线之间的夹角
很可能就把一个天井的窗子整个漏掉了
所以这事呢就是说unix 3的一个问题对吧
那么在这里面
我们发现一个很有意思的东西
这里面就是数学概念
我就不展开讲了
哎这里面有一个很有趣的概念叫pdf对吧
probability distribution function叫pdf
这个不是我们的打印的文档的pdf啊
它就是一个数学上的一个定义
就是说我如果对这个函数的分布
它哪些地方有这个强烈的信号来
一定要
实际上我如果采样也按照这个probability
进行分布的话
那我其实就可以用尽可能少的采样
获得尽可能逼近于它
想要的就是那个那个真实值对吧
就比如说我的信号是这样的
那么我的这个pdf的话呢
如果是下面的这样一个波峰波谷的话
这个可以在数学上证明啊
就是这种采样肯定是比uniform采样
就同样的三零read是呀
如果你真的是纯随机的话
它会更好地帮我求出它的积分
这个数学上我就不展开了
但是呢这个概念其实也很简单
比如说我在做设定的时候对吧
我尽可能朝着光比较亮的地方
尽可能沿着我的法线的这个正对的地方
去多设一些采样的锐
那这样的话我可以用少量的锐
就可以获得我想要的结果
对不对
那其实这个东西的话呢
在我们过去讲什么
无论是基于这个所有做解压的方法
比如说啊我让我回想一下这个地方
我可能会有一点不一定对
比如说我们最早做radiosity复数度算法
基于retracing的算法对吧
monocle retracing对吧
比如说还有风投来品对吧
其实基本上所有的这种方法大家都会
如果一个基础方法提出来之后
就会有无数的这个这个衍生的work
就是在讨论说怎么去做它的important
三零
在同样的计算时间下
或者说这个在同样的采样率下
我能达到一个更好的
更稳定的
更smooth的效果
如果大家搜索过去十几年的这个
graphics paper的话
你会发现有大量的这样的工作存在
而且这些工作呢
这个实际上是有非常大的实战价值的
所以这个是我们去理解gi算法的
一个核心的技术点好
那其实的话呢就是刚才已经讲到了
就说哎那我要是这个做running的时候
我的pdf怎么选呢
哎这里面就很简单了
比如说回想我们的render equation对吧
那我们最好的这个pf是什么呢
哎大家想到了
如果我的反射
大部分我可以假设是debu面的话
但你的这个我对光的这个敏感度
是不是这个诶一基本满足一个deflop对吧
就是你越这个基本上是你靠近我
normal的方向
我会敏感一点对吧
就扩散嘛
然后呢你如果从侧面射来的光的话
其实就算你光线很强
我的感应度其实也是一般对吧
那这个default loop是很正常的
那么如果更猛一点的话
比如说你假设是这个啊
那这样的话我们就比较一个例子吧
进行这种广场的这个积分的话
你可以发现同样是256个
那个那个那个就是sampling per pixel s s p p
你会发现它有很多噪点
但是呢如果我们按照cos loop去分布
我们的点就是靠近那个天顶的那个地方
我分布的稍微密一点对吧
靠近下面我分布的稍微稀疏一点诶
我这个时候采样的噪点数就会下降很多
同样是256个sp
那么对于那种非常glossy的东西的话
打个比方啊
比如说像这种符合gg x x材质的
大家还记得我们在前面讲的时候
讲过gg s对吧
我们理解那个就是那个p b2 的时候
就讲过gg s g s
我记得以前我给大家讲的
就是它的特点是什么
跟音响一样的
叫高频足够尖
足够高a但是呢低频音域足够宽对吧
这是jjs方程的一个特点
那么简单来讲
gg s它个loop呢
会比cos会更加的sharp一点诶
那如果我基于normal
基于g s我去进行优化的话呢
实际上我可以就是能够抓住更好的
glossy的这种效果
但是实际上这个东西是一个很
我觉得很specific的东西
它不具有普遍意义对吧
那么所以呢在这里面我们讲的这一part的话
就让大家理解
就是说gi这个东西
它的核心就是说你要去找到一个好的一个
sample方法
用尽可能少的瑞去获取
一个来自于四面八方的光场
对你影响的
这样的一个一个一个一个一个一个
怎么说呢
一个表达
也就是说我对于每个屏幕上的每个像素点
就是这是一小配match
然后我需要知道说哎
我的前上下左右光到底是怎么样呢
我就去我就发瑞去问
那这个问他讲究
就是说你要问在正确的地方问
在重要的地方
其实这里面讲的三里只讲了那个
你表面才知自己其实呢还有跟光有关系
所以这是我们在过去啊算gi的时候
经常会想到的问题
遇到的问题好
这是我们的基础知识好
接下来呢我们就讲诶在这个real time rendering
我怎么用
为什么呢
前面我讲的这些gi啊
michelle retracing啊
至少在呃很多年以来吧
他是一个研究了很多年的一套算法
以前都是离线算法
什么意思
都是说在cpu上跑
但是呢它基本上是说电影for
这个就是这些领域去应用
因为大家在我们普遍的尝试
我认为就是g i的东西
播游戏的话实在是太废了对吧
那从大概十几年前就有一些非常厉害的
这个同志们就再去想一个问题了
就是说诶我们有没有可能把gi做成real time
真的在游戏这样的场景里面能用起来
所以我个人去理解啊
就是说这实际上是lumen的这个算法
它的源头的思想
那我首先呢要讲一个老祖宗的算法
叫reflective shadow map rsm
这是一个2005年的工作
这个工作
为什么我会放到今天的第一趴来讲呢
因为就是说我个人认为啊
他是这一系列的方法的
一个就是说开山鼻祖就让启发了很多人
让大家敢于想象说啊
原来real time机啊我也是可以做的对吧
那么这个reflective shmap呢
它核心解决的问题是什么呢
就是说我怎么把光注入到这个场景里面去
诶这个问命题听起来有点抽象啊
这其实确实是有点抽象
那么当然了
因为我们很多同学可能没有学过
这个系统的图形学
其实在图形里面我们算gr有两类方法
一类最经典的就是蒙特卡拉retracing
对吧
那我们就是从屏幕射光
然后不停的放肆放肆放肆放肆
这种方法是一个很经典的方法
但其实呢还有一个很著名的方法
是这个叫ftmapping
我不知道大家有没有听说过这个词
这个词儿红糖产品还是一个很棒的方法
这如果我没记错的话
也是一个在我们腾讯学的黄金年代吧
也是一个英雄辈出的那个年代拍的
我应该没记错
应该是拍的harry哈
去这个写的
他是stanford的一个大教授
然后呢他有一本书叫冯特map这么厚
然后普通mp的思想非常有意思
他说你们以前都是从相机那边去看对吧
我看到一个物体
我看那个物体有多少东西能照亮他
对不对
他说不行
我要从光那边看
他说呢你们看到所有的东西啊
实际上都是从光源射出来的光子对吧
然后呢打到了物体表面
不停的反弹反弹反弹
然后呢你人眼的collect收集到了这些光子
所以你们的retracing呢都是从眼睛倒着去搞
仔细想想
对不对
那为什么我们不去政治搞呢
用光学的最基础的概念
就是从光的角度去看这个问题呢
所以风头外面呢就算我今天不展开
其实哎呀今天时间实在来不及了
如果按照我的性子的话
我可能花两页给大家讲讲phone map的技术方法
但简单讲了红糖发病的算法是这样的
就是说我是cost无数的风头
然后呢到一定条件
它在那个光子就会停留在物体表面
然后你最后shaking的时候呢
其实那就是他的那个radiance
就是每一个表面点上
它它的整个光的那种分布诶
你在做设定的时候
就在这些收gather
好的这些风头上面进行收集
进行插值
然后最后给出这个设定
这个就是photo mapping的一个核心思想
大家如果有兴趣的话
可以查这个这个资料
其实我自己去看整个lumen的这一脉的工作
我个人觉得起始于rs呃
只起于l r3 m
终于这个就是说lumen的话
其实蛮有一点封腾map的味道
当然我不是原作者对吧
所以我不能猜测揣测他心里在想什么
反正我作为一个外人去看他的时候
我觉得老哥
你这个想法好像跟风台外面的思路很像嘛
好那就不展开了
因为现在讲起来太抽象了
那我们先讲什么叫reflective china
他的想法其实非常简单
它基于一个observation
就是说我们在选英语的时候
我们是不是要选一只shadow map
对不对
那大家觉得china map和我们正常的渲染
最大的不同是什么
他是从我们正常的渲染是从相机视角去看
而shadomap呢实际上是什么呢
是从光的视角去看的
所以说我在炫耀shut map的时候
我只取了一个depth
对不对
但是大家想想
如果我在shut up那个camera
那个那个那个那个那个位置的话
我把场景整个炫一遍
如果我把它再沿着这个光设定一遍的话
你其实是不是得到了
如果这个世界上没有积压的话
只有deflighting的话
是不是所有被照亮的面都在那个map里面
对不对
所以我个人是觉得那个reflective shadow map
这个词啊
其实是非常让大家confuse
因为shadow map你会觉得它是shadow吗
就是变黑的东西吗
其实他那个是什么呢
他那个实际上是我觉得叫做呃啊mination map啊
radiance map什么都好
我觉得挺好的
就是他就是在相机位置
然后呢就是啊从光的位置
你看到的所有被照亮的表面
注意啊
从从光的角度
如果光没有multbs的话
其实那张图里面看到的
如果你是一个一个spotlight
就是说是一个追星光的话
还真的就是所有被第一次照亮的表面
不会多一个像素
也不会少一个像素
大家仔细想想
是不是这个道理
诶这个rs就是基于这个想法
那如果我现在知道
就是所有在空间中被照亮的点
以及它被照亮的第一次照亮的时候
它的亮度的时候
这个亮度它可以散射出来
对不对
散射出来
那我在渲染任何一个
我眼睛看到的点的时候
我是不是把这些空间上的这些被照亮的点
诶
把它的散射出来的radiance全部收集一下
我是不是就可以照我的点了
大家想对不对
这个想法其实非常简单
那所以呢这里面这张图呢是原作者的图
我个人觉得这个图画的
其实非常的confuse啊
我今天不好意思啊
今天我也是跟大家现学先买
大家权当我是这个教研组内paper reading的节奏
就教练组内ping的时候
我们是赶黑原作者的
我们说原组的图画的很不好
如果公开课让我们不敢讲呢
因为我们怎么敢diss这个这个原作者呢
所以今天如果我什么地方讲错了
冒犯了大家
一定要原谅我
比如说我就觉得这张图画的
非常的confused对吧
你其实明明要讲的是这个xp那一点
对下面那个被照亮的那x那一点的影响
你为什么还要画一个
就是这个x q那一点
你还画一个y那个点就非常的confuse
真的我看的就是当时这个图
我看着就非常的晕
所以我就用加了两个篮筐放在这儿
就是说其实那个下面的公式呢
它讲的就是就是光射到了
而且那个图画的特别特别糟糕的
一点是什么
我给大家讲的就是那个上面是一个光源
他结果在那给我画了个camera
我也想
我也特别想喷他对吧
你那是个光嘛对吧
camera应该是我这样看过
就算camera
当然如果我理解错了
大家对吧
我记得那期年利奇讲到这一趴的时候
他有一趴讲那个四次方
他说要吃键盘
那我目前觉得我也可以
如果我这段讲错了
我可能也可以是键盘好不好
可以吧
就是我觉得那个上面那个画的相机
那个位置实际上是一个光
当然他可能那个是一个探照灯头对吧
看着很魔性对对
反正如果换成我的话
我可能换个大灯泡在那边
那么那你这个光呢射到xp那一点对吧
根据xp的
就是那个那个那个那那一面被照亮的话
它会有个法向
那这样的话我就可以算出来说
根据number是模型对吧
你沿着各个角落
你就有这个散射系数
对不对好
那我对于x这点来讲的话
我就可以把那边的那个radiance给接过来
然后呢再给我自己进行shading
那我就知道了那个我的多少在这里面
注意
就是这个readings衰减呢
是按照距离的平方衰减
那么这里面有一个梗啊
就是令其讲到这一趴的时候
他说哎呀这个东西一定是二次方
不应该是四次方对吧
我跟大家老实的交代啊
我昨天前两天我备课的时候
我也对着黑板敲了半天
我觉得这是平方
怎么可能是四次方呢
后来我们吵了大概五分钟之后
十分钟之后突然一下子意识到
卧槽不对
因为它上面那个就是那个xp减x啊
还有x减x p
它没有规划
就是它实际上还是一个带长度的一个向量
所以它下面除四次方
本质上是做了个规划而已
所以四方真的是对的是吧
确实很有意思
但是我觉得原作者真的有点坑人对吧对
因为因为确实你很容易就会晕掉
但是呢他这样写也是有道理的
可能对于从shader实现来讲是速度最快的
这是r s m的一个核心想法
ok好
那就很简单了嘛
那我既然知道
就是说诶对于x这个点来讲的话
对我的第一个光源我就找到了xp对吧
那以此类推
我可不可以把reflection杀在web上的
每一个点都去搂一遍对吧
把你根据你们的距离啊
根据你们的头像
我这个方向观察
实际上我做了一个积分
是不是就能得到我想要的点
诶这个方法就对了对吧
但这个方法呢有个问题是什么呢
太粗暴了
因为你想啊我的rs 3 m对吧
我选的最少
比如说512x512
那也是将近有这个啊
将近有几10万个点了
对不对
那你怎么可能就是全每个像素
就是每个screen speed像素都做一遍呢
诶他又提出了一个想法
说我呢搞一个空tracy对吧
他其实这个空缺他是个hack
他那个时候还没想明白这个事
他就说呢
诶我我去随机的按照各个方向去去打
然后呢
如果我打的近
打得远
我实际上就意味着我这个空啊
再再扩散对吧
那对于扩散的空大的地方
我给的权重高一点
扩散空小一点
我给的权重小一点
其实这样的一个方法它实际上就能够完成
就有点像蒙特卡罗是睡醒一样的
我就对诶
那我刚才讲的那个词叫billions of leslighthouse对吧
那无数个小光源进行一次随机采样
他自己的原文中
他说的400多个三浦基本够用了
而且他是要用破破的方法分布这个三步
但是后面的人有很多更好的方法
但是呢他就是说啊
就能得到一个基本可以的一个结果
那么其实呢这里面one more step
就是说实际上它这个空tracing啊
在后面的工作中
大家可以发现就是我可以对r3 m7 做me
做秘书的好处
就是说我可以直接去sampling
比较高密谱的这个rs
这样的话呢
我觉得一次性我能三破的这个空会更大
如果你是非常debus的面对吧
但是如果你是非常gloss这边的话呢
诶我就去三破的密比较低的点
我就要在那个尖角的地方多采样
这个地方就不至于细节我不展开
但是确实是
作为一个2005年的工作的话
我觉得已经非常了不起了
是啊你现在已经有17年了对吧
那么其实呢
这里面还有一个很有意思的思路
他说呢哎虽然说我只需要做400次采样
我就能得到first bounce的gi的效果
但是的话呢这个还是很费
那我怎么办呢
我把屏幕用half pixel
就是我我每隔两个我做一次对吧
这个时或者是每个四个都可以
那么这个时候呢我就去进行sa建议呃
我在做做那个shading的时候
因为我只是做那个低频的那个in indirect
innovation
借机光照
间接光照
大家都知道它是低频的
它不像直接光照那么高频诶
这个时候实际上呢
我收集过了低频的那个intrination的话
实际上可以旁边的pixel都可以共用
这是也是一个非常了不起的发现啊
因为我们后面再讲的那个lumen的那个
就是那个screen space的那个prop的时候
他为什么16x16就work了
其实他自己讲
我有个什么伟大的observation对吧
但其实从这个rs m时代
大家就已经发现了这件事情
就是interstation
我可以用低频
就是在screen space屏幕空间
我可以很低频的去采样
我就可以去拿它
那么这个时候呢
他又提出了一个非常有益的思想
就是说诶我对于每一个渲染的像素
我要去用这些更稀疏
采样的这些这个ation的时候呢
我发现一个问题
就是说如果我我的那个采样点跟我
比如说那个空间位置相差特别大
或者是法向朝向很不公
我位置很不共
面对吧
那我就想办法
我认为这是个无效的一个这个差值
那我要把这个差值踢掉
他肯定自己遇到了很多artifact的
所以呢他发现这个问题
他他就把这些得不到有效差值的
这些pixel呢把它标出来
这些pixel呢量不大
对于整个屏幕来讲
可能不到1%甚至1‰
哎这1‰的pixel
我呢啊对他进行这种一次完整的采样
其实这个方法非常的了不起
因为这个observation其实大家如果研究呃
像lumen里面的很多差距上吧
它的核心思想就这样
就屏幕上我有100万个像素点对吧
那我用这种这个低密度的这个光的采样
然后呢插值到每一个像素点
对它进行光照的时候
大部分时候是work的
但是架不住有些时候他work怎么办
其实这个思想源头的话
我在r semi就已经看到
这个是非常的有意思的一点好
那这个方法呢其实又简单
其实也是work
早很早以前
无论是girls war啊
就是还有那个girls for war
还有uncharted for
这里面其实都已经实现了这个
所以你可以看到一些手电筒照的那诶
旁边就照亮的效果
因为r3 m真的能做这件事
而且他的案例里面用的也是个spotlight对吧
我刚才黑了一下那张图
画的不好
说不定人家说我就是特别适合做手电筒
人家说的说不定说不定是对的
那其实呢我觉得就是为什么
我这这这是我很个人情感化的表达
就是非常感谢r s m
因为我认为他是个非常inspiring的一个work
你看他这两个老哥是原作者的言论文对吧
那么我觉得他非常easy
第二个的就是说他实际上第一次啊
这至少是我自己研究
我自己总结下来
我发现他可能是我找到了第一个工作
就是想到了用这个方法
把这个光子真的注入到这个世界了对吧
第二个的话呢
诶他在那个这句话写的不一定对
就是我我今天我们团队又查了一下
觉得好像他没有想到用mmap的方法
就是那个rs m码的方法
去实现高效率的空contracing
然后呢还有一个很重要的思想
就是说诶
我可以在low resolution的screen space
里面去采集这些这个间接光照
同时呢我在真正渲染的时候
我在这个低频采样里面进行插值
但是我加上一个error check
而且他也研发了一些早期的err车的方法
能够保证就是尽量减少这种artifact
当然了他这里面其实有很多的局限呢
毕竟是个早期算法
所以呢它只能解决single bce啊对吧
他而且他也不检测visibility对吧
它会假设就是说
因为他他去向那光采样的时候
他一步检测的时候
我这个光是不被被遮挡
所以它其实有很多的artifact
但是呢毫无疑问
我觉得r s m是一个
非常具有启发性的一个工作
所以大家去理解一些基础的思路
都积压在记录的时候
这个思路这个文章的话是
大家一定要简单的去读一读的这个工作好
那么有了rs m这个东西的时候呢
哎我们接下来就想我们该干点什么了对吧
那既然光子已经住进去了
那我们就要让这个光在这个世界里面
流动起来呢
这里面就介绍一个我个人认为是一个啊
怎么说呢
是一个非常inspiring idea
就是非常启发我们的想法
但是个人觉得他的数学上
好像是有那么一丢丢问题的
这么一个工作叫lpv
叫light propagation volu
就是在空间中传递光的
这样的一个一个个的涡轮
对吧
好哎这个这句话好像说的跟废话似的对吧
不好意思
我也不知道怎么去表达他
那么其实呢最早是在cg 3里面
就是c cpp 2009年
距离现在大概13年前
有一个这个c应该是cos去讲了
他是怎么去做这件事情的
他的核心想法怎么样呢
哎这地方我要倒一下我师弟的图了
闫妮琪的这个图
我觉得这个图画的非常的灵魂
我很喜欢我
我怀疑他可能是用格子纸画的
所以天然就具有这个vox lize的
这个这个东西对吧
它就是世界
我把世界分成无数的格子
然后呢当我的光就照到这每个格子里面
格子里面如果有物体的话
我的这些光就会在里面形成bouncing
就会形成一样的ance的这个radiance
这样的分布对吧
当我去设定任何一个点的时候
这个这个它其中纸张看过去的话
应该是camera space
诶
我camera不是任何一个点的话
我就可以去把这些wallet
里面的东西给它取出来对吧
这张图就是一个非常灵魂的一个表达
确实是就是说想象一下我的空间
把它分成无数个大格子对吧
整个场景扔进去
光的射进去
那其实对于所有物体的地方的话
这些东西就会形成一个诶
光的这个四面八方散射的这种叫reading
你可以认为它是个cube吧
也不是cube
说错了
是一个是个sfile
就是一个球面分布的一个函数对吧
这个函数的话呢
实际上你的整个东西被照亮
就是基于这个球面分布的函数
那这个时候我怎么去做这种这个light
这种multipx啊
这些所有的效果呢
诶他老人家有一个很核心的东西
其实这个算法本身很长了对吧
很长
我觉得你不长个
因为今天重点要讲ler
所以哦对跟大家声明一下
就是今天我讲的所有的在lumen之前的算法
都是点到为止
并不会讲它的细节
其实每个算法后面都有很多的细节
那为什么呢
因为我要每个算法都讲的很细的话
那差不多这本身可以讲大概呃六七节课
没有什么太大的问题对吧
但是呢今天我们只有一节课的时间
我们讲len
所以时间已经快接近一个小时了
所以我要抓紧时间
那么这里面的话呢
我觉得最关键的是这个诶
他的light怎么去propagation
在这一个个的vocsol里面怎么去propagation
他的想法其实非常的淳朴啊
就是说他这个radiance
照到这些像素里面之后
你不表现物体对吧
我就把在这个worko里面的话
这个这个这个就是说四面八方的
这个反射的四面方的radio
我把它全部这个三骂就合到一起
那怎么合呢
这个是个球面的分布函数对吧
你怎么和这很麻烦
对不对
你你多少个采样点才合适呢
诶他突然想到一个数学工具了
我为什么不用ssh呢
是发红外x对吧
这个时候伟大了
surf红帽x就起了作用
为什么呢
因为你无才
无论你采集无数个这个表面上的点
其实它的这个贡献
其实都可以用加权累积在一起
他最后就可以用一个s去表达这个函数
就特别的好
所以呢我就得到了一个在这个worker里面
你的radiance的一个在空间上的分布场
那我有任何一个物体
我想设定用它来shading的时候
实际上用这个s就可以拿得到好
那这个时候其实对于每个worker
我就可以拿到它内部光照的s h对吧
那实际上的话呢
哎我假设有表面上的这些worko的话
我其实在空间上可以向无数个voxel
去扩散
这个扩散的话呢
他的想法就是哎我都是通过一个编码
我从左边出去对吧
我我就也以前s h的这一部分
我推到一套数学方程
我就传到另外一面去了
然后呢
这种扩散呢本身呢有一个词叫propagation啊
这张图特别的迷啊
就是说就是我当时的问题就是诶
你这个radiance扩散出去之后
你这个box one内部还有没有readers
如果你内部的radiance还在的话
那不好意思
你的能量是不守恒的对吧
你的radiance如果不在那个地方就是青黑啊
那为什么你们还能被照亮
你看到他最后那个propagation的感觉
像是一种扩散的效果对吧
它甚至clan我可以做multi bs
但是呢我们自己在做数学推导的时候
我们会发现这个好像感觉
你这个光的扩散的这个这个速度
扩散的范围跟你做了多少次
你都是有关
这种感觉就像是说呃
光是由有限速度
在各个这个voxel里面去传递的
所以所以其实我们在找原文啊
最后发现就是说lpv的方法
就是感觉它不太符合物理学原理
实话实说
然后呢
第二个的话呢就是说呃
这里面有很多的hack
很多的细节
我们现在想不清楚
但是呢就是说他作为一个17年前的一个
老的算法呃
呃十大概15年前的老算法
我觉得13年前
我觉得他肯定有他自己的想法
因为为什么提这个算法呢
我觉得最核心的就是他是第一个想到说
我把空间进行workout的划分
在每个worker里面去
cash这个radiance是怎么分布的
而且他想到说把这东西扔到s 10去了
因为扔到s 10有很多好处
大家在前面讲到那个p p2 的时候
讲的l那个那个那个那个那个来image
baib 2的image barendering时候
大家就会发现
就是说诶我球面上来了个天光对吧
我把它变成s h
就可以用我的这个b2 df进行卷积了
对不对
所以说这些东西呢
我认为都是他很好的一个工作
但是这个工作呢我个人觉得就是说太老了
而且很多东西没有讲的特别清楚
反正我是没有讲明白
如果没有想明白
如果同学们有人真的看懂了
而且呢真的能彻底的理解它的物理学
意义的话
也希望同学们跟我们分享一下
反正呃我个人觉得呢
它这个东西呢没有完全搞明白
不太影响就是对norman的理解
而在这之后呢
其实大家的方法就会更加的科学了
那这里面的话就会提到一个大名鼎鼎的
叫s v o g i了对吧
这个呢是nvidia同学们都做的工作
这个老哥的想法呢其实非常的淳朴
就是说ok如果你对空间进行voxel划分
对吧
你分得多粗呢
分的多细呢对吧
你分的太粗
那你其实不能够准确地表达
这个世界里面的光的这个分布
那你要分得太细
那我就有无数的worko诶
但是我们很自然的就知道
就是说其实呢你很多时候空间里面是空的
是没有worker的
而且很多时候worker呢你只需要存它的表面
里面的东西
你看不见
你也不需要对吧
诶他们就提了一个方法
说我能不能用硬件的叫保守观赏画
保守观上听上去很高大上啊
但是你简单理解它
就是说对于那种很小的三角形
对于很薄的三角形
它至少能保证诶你有一个pixel在那边
那你你对这个三角形进行三个方向照
照片的时候
把这个pixel这个三方向投影
你是不是就能得到他的works的表达
对不对
那好保守
光栅化
它就能保证就是说这个再薄再小的三角形
它也能够works alize
这个其实在lumen里面啊
我想看他在莫斯沃克斯莱先生的时候
是用了这个技术的
对
好哦
然后呢哦他没有追求
他用了另外一个就不展开
不重要
重要的是这个诶
那这样的话
我就把所有的surface的worko全部都收集起来
这个手看上去是不是特别的细腻
特别的漂亮
那我要表达这个空间就会非常的大
对不对
那很自然而然的嘛
凡事不许怎么上树嘛
我们就上了一个诶八叉树对吧
为什么是八叉树
大家知道空间上我的每一个维度上的二分
那在空间上的就是二的三次方
八八次分对吧
那我就是里面没有物体
我就分得特别特别的粗
直到分到有物体
这时候我对空间的形成的表达
但实际上你们去看原文的实现的时候啊
是非常复杂的
对于每一个节点
它不仅存了自己
它还存了周围的三个邻居啊
就是左边一个右边一个
上面一个
下面就是就是周围
就把原来1x1变成3x3
为什么呢
因为他很多时候要做filtering的时候
诶
他做bina trainia templation的时候
我需要我的零
所以那个数据结构是惊人的复杂
那这件事情的话
我们我们最近在整备课的时候
我们就努力的想找到它的源代码
但是很遗憾的是
我们这个信息渠道不够充沛
我们没有找到源代码
我们很关注的一些细节
所以啊这个s v o g i的话
实际上mad给出了一个demo之后
其实就没有太多的这些就是细节的表达了
但是呢
用这种这个这个ospark box tra的这个思想
其实是一个非常啊怎么说呢
非常经典的一个思路
因为大家在前面学到我们的引擎
running man的时候
好多次
很多地方大家都看到
用了一个就是稀疏的八叉树
对不对
就是基本上你只要空间结构表达
这个就是一个很自然的想法
嗯
他所以我理解他们就是真的是
把这个很自然的淳朴的想法
在这个就是十几年
现在硬件上硬生生的把它实现了一遍
如果我没记错的话
一个工作
或者11年12年左右的一个工作
差不多现在有10年左右对吧
那个时候我们的computer shor啊
这些东西还不算特别成熟
刚刚开始那个时代
那在这里面的话
还有一个非常有意思的想法
这个想法其实对后面的很多工作
影响特别大
就是说我去这个时候
当我去设定任何一个物体的表面的时候
诶
我实际上不是一个在球面上的一个积分吗
那我怎么样呢
我采样呗
对不对
我采样的话
如果我只是采样一根锐的话
那你可能要采样几百根瑞
才能达到理想的效果
对不对
那他的想法是什么呢
诶第一个我根据我的法向啊
根据这些东西
我可以猜出来说哪些地方对我比较重要
然后我想我重要的地方呢踩的不是一个锐
是一根空好
那这个空的特点就是一个一个空的
英文的意思就是圆锥
它这个这个这个圆锥体啊展开的时候
它实际上在worko那个表达里面
是不是
他到后来会扫到越来越大颗粒的voxel
对不对
那你这个worko对空间的表达
是一个树状结构
就越往这个数越靠近根节点的话
它每个我所表达的空间区域就越大
所以你那个时候你只要取到一个worker的值
实际上可能就是一个很大面积的
这个radiance的一个和对吧
是他的一个平均
所以这是个非常巧妙的思想
就是你用这个思想的话呢
你实际上就可以反向的就可以查到
就是说你的光照到底是什么东西
所以这个思想实际上的话呢
在这个我觉得是s u g i里面
大家最早提出来的
我认为这思想其实非常的好
因为你只要对空间进行hierarchy的这种
works lize的表达的话
你就有这样一个优势
就像我刚才讲的r s m对吧
它是那个光光
你可以认为它是对空间的光的一个表达
那么你对它进行一层一层的密p的话
你实际上也能大概能实现这样的
一个效果啊
23m行不行哦
对他不行
他那个因为他每个pixel其实表达的是
在空间上可能距离很远的这个点
ok但是worklife的表达确实有这个好处
所以这个是一个contracing
那么其实呢很遗憾s b u g i的话
很多细节我们查不到对吧
但是也不重要
因为实际上没有人在用这种算法
原因很简单
那个spark spark archittree那个数据结构啊
在gpu上表达非常的复杂
那那一页被我去掉了
它其实是什么
一层index指向另外一层index
而且你指向的每个node的话
他存的不是自己的数据
它是从它前后左右
上下邻居的数据全存一遍对吧
然后的话一层层要保证
这个数据都是一致的
怎么去对他们进行mini map场景更新了
怎么办啊
一堆的hack的细节
但是呢这是所有的这个这个所有的hack
当v x积压来了之后
一切都被变成了浮云
为什么呢
大家突然发现一件事情
我为什么要这么麻烦呢
对吧
我为什么要把整个场景做进去呢
对于一个gr来讲
对于我来说最重要的事情是什么
不就是我眼睛看到的这一片区域吗
对不对
那我眼睛看到的这片区域丢了呀
最重要的是什么呢
离我近处的区域啊
远处的远处的虚拟机还重不重要重要
但是呢我不需要对它进行很高精度的采样
诶
这个时候我们传统的clip map的思想就来了
这里面我小小吐槽一下
就是那个clip map这个词
我觉得中文翻译其实挺糟糕的
叫什么剪切剪切图剪切面
其实clip这个词英文的原意是什么
是回形针
所以可以map在我的理解中
它就像你一沓文件对吧
比如说我用一个回形针把它别到一起
它就形成了一就随手拿起来就是一组对吧
但是这个中文翻译我也想好怎么翻译啊
但是确实他的那个中文翻译
确实让大家很confused
其实clip map的意思更像是说诶
我这些图最大的一张图1/2尺寸
1/4存这些东西
我用回形针把它全叠到一起
你这一拎对吧
最上一层只有一张明星
只有一张名片那么大
最下面那张可能是张a4 纸那么大
诶你这个一拿就走
这感觉是不是很形象对吧
其实那我对空间的workalize的表达的话
实际上也可以用clip map的这个方法
那很简单嘛
就是说离我相机近的地方
比如说方言呃
50米
30米啊
方圆50米对吧
我用很密的这个这个vocal去表达
离我远一点的话呢
哎我粗一点
比如说半径这个最近的地方
比如半径0.5米对吧啊
每个vocal 0.5米远的地方呢就远一点
每个下一层是每个vox一米
我就能表达50米对吧
再远一点是什么2米
我就能表达1百米
再再下一层的话
每一个是比如说这个这个4米对吧
我现在表达这个1百米范围
一般来讲做到12百米就差不多了对吧
既然很多时候
你假设就是你在这个人的这个位置的话
这么远就可以了
那这样的话
我就不要这么费劲巴拉的去构建一个
sparse稀疏的ocitra结构
因为大家知道
稀疏的oxy结构是非常非常复杂
很难管理的
那这样的话
我其实还是构建了一个树状结构
只是这个树状结构的话呢
是一个非常好的view dependent destiny distribution
所以vx jr为什么最后在这一这一盘里面
几乎是这个碾压性的取代了suv g啊
也就是个道理
因为他对gpu更加的friendly
而且实现起来更加的清晰明确简单
那么这个时候呢
哎这里面要讲一个细节
就是那场景里面你相机总是在动
怎么办对吧
那我怎么办呢
哎我这个这个clip map的话
我总是要更新的
这里面讲了一个细节
就是说就是那个可循环的这个uv
其实非常简单
就是说我设置你的宽度之后
我实际上在存储的地方是拿你的空间的xyz
记住是空间的xy啊
size的x y
这样的好处是什么呢
当你的相机发生了变化之后
我的那个原来做的那些数据啊
它其实不用在内存中更新速速更新位置
也就是说
无论你是在内存还是应该主要是在显存
在gpu中
你只要去覆盖掉另外那边的那个数据
实际上你做三破零的时候
你的数据是不会发生错误的
这是一个小的trick
但这个trick实际上在lm里面
它很多地方都用到了这样的一个trick
这样的好处就是说但这电影给大家讲
就是如果我们要做这个
比如说啊
比如说virtual texture呀
很大的世界的空间的表达
我我我今天要做个cash结构对吧
跟我的没有dependent
我的相机就随着我一直在动对吧
那这个数据在空间上uv怎么去packing呢
用这个思路是最好的
为什么呢
因为你每次只需要更新更新他边上那些数
据
边上那些数据呢
它其实是反向的
又写回来了
而不需要把中间那些没有
没有必要更新的数据重新给它一个位置
因为大家知道在内存中
你做一次memory copy其实是很慢的
在显存中呢
你去牵引一下那个速度可能就更慢
为什么显存那个就是gpu
你还得等一个下一个更新周期过来
那个就很麻烦了对吧
这里面我们就不中奖了
重点讲了
ok好
那实际上的话
这样的话我对整个空间就有一个workless
这个这样从近处到密
远处到稀疏的表达
大家看这个图里面进出
他的vocal明显就细一点
远处呢粗一点诶
但是你有没有发现
好像远处也没有显得特别粗
对不对
诶
你有这样的一个视差
感觉就是对了
为什么呢
因为远处它实际上voxel是越来越大
但是呢它基本上保证在screen space
给你感觉没有那么特别明显的变化
实际上它已经离你很远了
接下来我们看到月亮和太阳对吧
月亮和太阳看起来一般大
但是大家知道
月亮和太阳正好直径相差400倍
距离相差400倍
所以你看上去就是一样的对吧
就科普一个天文学的小知识啊
好所以呢这个就是空间上的
你可以看到这样的一个vocal的
这样的一个表达
ok好
那接下来就很简单了
就是说这里面是一个细节
就是说其实每个vocal啊
它不是纯黑或者纯白
就是能透光还是不透光
实际上呢它每一个workle
实际上是有一个opie
就是你光从这边射过去的时候
因为你的worker毕竟是一个
1米乘1米的一个大方格对吧
你把一个mesh放进去
你很可能光透了多少
透了55%对吧
挡住了45%
对不对
这个时候其实你要沿着它各个方向
算出它的opposity
算出它的那个就是说不透明度
为什么呢
当我积积分一个点的光照的时候
我在近处的voxl
可能近处就有vocal里有东西
但是呢它实际上里面可能只放了一只小
班里对吧
他只挡住了这龌龊的
可能是1/3的地方
好你另外2/3实际上是继续要往后走
我当时我也讲的就是
其实这个就是基于这个vocal的
这个这个方法的话呢
你的沿着这条光路啊
一个空tracing下去的话
它是一个一层层叠加的过程
不像大家想到的时候
我hit一个box
我就停在了
其实不是的
它是一个有半透明效果的
所以呢这里面你在一开始build这个
就是voxel的时候
你实际上是有一个叫a pity的词
但注意呢这个pcity的人比较复杂
就是说他基本上每个方向
应该是三个方向都要算一遍
就是从左右看诶
他可能透了30%对吧
从上下看透了70%
从这个这个前后看可能透了50%
它是不一样的
因为大家想三维空间的一个形体嘛对吧
所以这个opacity你可以理解成
就是它的这个阿尔法好
那这个时候呢
这个地方就是我们把一个directional coverage
展现出来
大家可以看到
还有很多半透的或者灰色的取值
对于一个场景而言好
那这个时候呢我们的light用r s m
就是用那个就是那个reflex map注入进去
那这个时候呢
我们在每一个表面的vocal上
都去收集他的radiance
然后这个时候呢
我这这是我们第一次光照下去
大家可以看到这些被照亮的worko
这里面为什么只有这些点会亮的
就只有这些点他是接受到了直接光照
其他的点看不到
为什么呢
因为它全部被挡在shadow里面去了
而这个时候诶
我们对于每个屏幕上的像素对吧
我们就进行这种空吹ing
但是这个里面你可以发布
你可以那个热搜是不用全屏幕
也可以
因为在那个rs原始方法大家也知道
就是说他不用for resolution injure lighting
那个太废了
但没关系
我们就进行控
那么对于非常低
因为我屏幕上每个像素点
我知道你的roughness对不对
对于你非常diffuse的表面
我怎么办呢
哎我就沿着那个normal的normal为主轴
408354面八方五的扫一扫对吧
那么如果你表面是非常speaker怎么办
哎我就沿着那个反射方向反射向怎么算
很简单
你的normal拿到了
我眼睛看到了
对不对
我就开始沿着大概演的那个spark方向
去去搜一下
如果你那个地方是非常非常细的
这个speker的这个那个就是呃
非常非常光滑的表面
怎么办
我不仅沿着只沿着那个反射方向
去取那个间接光照
我还把那个空变得非常的细
我这样就穿过去对吧
所以这个时候呢
基于因为你的vocalist的表达
它是一层层的嘛
实际上我就可以就像刚才讲s p o g i
你们的思路一样的
就是我在这个clip map的不同的层
我就可以模拟这样的一个空缺性的结果
刚才讲到一个细节是什么
就是他即使你这根瑞
因为我我在retracing的时候呢
我实际上只能找那个中间那根线去走
对不对
我现在打到了一个vocal
我并不是因为打到vocal我就停了
那个vocal有直
但是呢如果他的这个opacity沿着这个方向
不唯一的话
说明什么
我这个光含着透露过去
对不对
就是那边的光还能透露过来
反过来了啊
那这时候怎么办
我再继续往后走
越往上走
我的面积越大的时候
诶
我就取那个clip map里面更高的
mp的那个worko
这样我一次性就能覆盖很大的区域
那这些那个他的阿尔法呢就会不断的变低
对吧
就像我们这个东西很像什么呢
很像一个
就大家知道
那个我们在绘制transparency的时候啊
就是大家都知道就是那个啊会染绘制透明
我记得我在渲染那一刻跟大家讲过
就是其实是现代图形学里面
很难的一个问题
return对吧
我们这么多年一直在研究一个叫order
indepenindependent transparency
但是so far好像大家也没搞出来对吧很难
那么实际上的话呢
如果场景里的透明物
我们都排好了序的话呢
那其实我们是知道怎么弄的
那同样的
就是对于这个就是空吹型来讲的话
我们沿着voxel就一路哒哒哒哒哒哒上去
这个这个透明物之间是被排好序的
所以我们把它阿尔法就不停的垒成垒成
垒成垒成
但是呢当你的阿尔法小于某个阈值的时候
对吧
很接近于零的时候
我们就说哎你反正已经不透明了算了
我们就不往后走了
所以这样能让我们的算法更快一点
所以呢它实际上就是along the read pass啊
每个voxl反射出来发射出来的radiance
然后呢把它opposity呢进行这个累积
直到这个满足我的那个阶段的阈值
所以这个东西呢其实挺重要的
ok好
那其实基于这个东西呢
我们就能得到一个a
非常不错的一个ci的效果
所以y x r实际上是一个
我个人认为是个蛮好的一个算法
实际上它也被实装了
我记得虚幻的有一代里面有一个插件
就可以实现vx t i
我我对这种所有能够实装的算法
我都是比较敬畏的
因为实际上你真的不敢把一个算法放出来
让大家在各种场景里测试的话
说明它本身的效率性能
而且我个人觉得vx i的话
他对s v gi的话是一个呃取代性的
这个地位
也就是说你有了vcr的话
我个人觉得没有必要再去搞s b u g啊
那么复杂的一套东西了对吧
我个人天生对复杂性系统我就比较抵触的
因为工程本身已经够难了对好
那么其实呢vx呢其实也有很多的问题了
比如说就是说唉实际上这种contracing啊
我们把这个opie累积
它是一个approximation对吧
那对于比如像这个case里面啊
三角形它在那个vocal里面
他只挡了部分的阿尔法对吧
那个黄色的方块它也挡了部分阿法
虽然他两个阿尔法如果按照乘法累积的话
它肯定不为零
对不对
但是在实际上光路上
如果你想象那是个平面啊
假假设不是三维平面
简单一点
它实际上那个里面的话
光已经是后面的vocal已经彻底无效了
但是呢我们没有办法进行有效的阻挡
这个呢其实就是我们看到的特点是什么呢
就是light leaking
光被漏掉了
特别是对于那种啊一些很薄
还有一些很薄的物体
它已经小于我最放的那个vocal
但是还有可能它本身不是啊很细
但是他距离我比较远
他只能用那个sparse的那个worko
去表达的时候
就是比较那个开lol worker表达的时候
光都会被漏过去
但这个所有的积压算法对吧
特别是早期的你都会遇到这个问题
这个问题其实是我们全局十roll time的节
哀的一生之敌
真的这真的是我们的一生之敌
我并不认为luna完全解决了这个问题
ok好
所以呢这就是那个vcr的一个问题
那么讲到这儿的话呢
基本上就是我们对空间的radiance啊
进行以vocal为单位
就是以一个个体数为单位
进行采样的思路对吧
到vx g i的话
我认为是这个这这一脉思路的集大成者
对吧
但是大家都是用了什么呢
哎都是用了r s m对吧
就是这个这个就是把风筒
把光子注入到了我们的世界里面去
然后呢你用voxel对吧
无论是这个平铺直叙的voxel
还是这个就是hierarchy worko
来收集这些这个光
注意这里面有个细节
就是所有的hierarchy base works的方法呢
它的一般都是做这种最fine level的vocal的
这个radiance的采集
采集完之后呢
它上面的密封呢都是用密码一层层上去的
这样的好处
就是说会减少一些不必要的计算量
而且这样的话它的数据其实会更加的准确
而且呢它相当于做了一次free
所以这个结果看上去会更加的我刚才讲了
g i的话
一做不好就会有很多的这种噪音的问题
好那这是一my思路
另外一门思路呢也是最近刚刚出来的
就是reen space los g i哎
这个screen space这个词就非常的好对吧
我记得我们在讲rning的时候
讲过a s s s a o对吧
屏幕空间的那个a o怎么算对吧
这个这个ss reflection screen space的反射
screen space gi的他的想法其实非常的淳朴
真的淳朴到极点了
这个文章呢这个工作呢最早是2015年
由寒霜first bad在那个gdc上
就是说这样的一个一个工作
那这个你现在大概7年前了对吧
它的方法其实是非常非常的巧妙
原始思想很简单
就是说我们看到一个场景对吧
上面红色框框的
就是我直接渲染出来的东西
那我去渲染它的indirect lighting的时候
假设你的表面非常的mirror的话
是不是只要在spring里面把它反一下
这些数据我就可以用了
对不对
所以我们在做spring space reflection的时候
就是用了这么淳朴的一个思想对吧
那好如果我们只设一根锐
我们能踩到它的这个reflection对吧
它的它的这个就是镜面反射的话
mirror flection的话
那我可不可以设多跟瑞
把这些渲染好的这些这些像素点
作为我的小光源
作为我全局光的小光源呢对吧
s s g i就是这么一个很淳朴的想法
非常淳朴对吧
那其实非常简单
就是说当我要设定一个这样的一个
黄色的点对吧
那我假设屏幕也选好了之后
我在我知道你的normal对吧
我知道我的相机的方向
我就跟着normal
沿着相机那个反过来那个方向
我去反发散的设一些锐
然后呢
这些瑞呢就在我的rs里面去找一个空间上
位置正确的点
那个点是亮的好
那就成我的闪光源对吧
那个点如果是红色
我就我知道了
我获得了一些红色的瑞典
那个点是个绿色
我就收到了一个绿色的瑞典
这样的话我就可以直接用屏幕空间的数据
进行这样的一个这个indirect lighting
你想大家想想这个想法是不是很淳朴对吧
哎这个想法实际上呢他真的work
就是说那好
那我怎么在screen space里面进行这个这个
这个进行这个remarching
就是recasting呢
它这里面一个最简单的做法是什么呢
就是remarching
大家如果听过我们前面节课
讲那个s s l的话
其实就知道这个方法其实很简单对吧
就是我从那个一个点出发对吧
我就开始设一个锐下去
这个r呢我就一路走走走
找一个虚拟的间隔对吧
那我只要找到有一点
他的depth比我那个dex更靠前
说明什么
说明我被挡住了
那这个时候呢我就认为我找到了一个焦点
那么其实呢这个就是fixed
那这个方法的话它是work
但是他要求那个间距特别特别的密
那这样的话是不是很慢
这里面就有一个很巧妙的算法
这个算法我需要给大家简单讲一讲
就是大家知道我们在讲shadow的时候
讲到那个action的时候
讲到那个就是遮挡的时候
讲到一个东西叫hiit
什么叫hz呢
就是说呃是gpu提供了一个算法
当然我们可以自己实现
那么在dx 12里面
很可能a啊应该是a p i就已经支持了
就是我在渲染的时候得到一个z8 分
它会自动的把我z8 法做成一层层的密码
但是呢它有个特点
就是说每一个上一层密布里面的这个点
他在下一次你不对应了四个点吗
那我在这四个点的depth里面
我选取那个最小值
就是离我最近的那个值
也就是说最突出的那个点对吧
你可以认为就是说我一个瑞
如果给你的孩子就给你开了
我的这个密度那个不相交的话
那我一定是不跟你相交了
但是呢如果我跟你相交了
那我有概率给你更细的某一个几何相交
所以它实际上把这个debuffer做成了一个
hierarchy的结构
然后呢在数学上它又保证了
就是说你你的那个
就是你你的每一层higher的那个z啊
它一定是下面的那个真正的那个z的
诶
这个就是一个就有点像它的bounding样的
就是每一层z就是shine
每每一层z都是他下一层z的那个bd对吧
那么好
当我有了hi的时候
我想做remarching呢
诶就比较简单了
我呢先往外走一格
发现我没有焦点
那我怎么办呢
我往hiit那一层往上跑一层
这样的话我做一次testing的时候呢
我就相当于走了两格对吧
这个时候如果我发现还没有焦点
我就开始胆子更大了
胆子更肥了
我在wp 8再往上走一层
我再做一次testing的话
我相当于做到了四个对吧
好诶
这个时候假设我不小心发现我hit了something了
对不对
但是呢刚才讲了hz呢
比如像这里面已经到了mp 2了对吧
我就知道他可能交到了mp 1
或者p0 的某个点叫到哪个点
我不知道
那好我再把这个把这个锐呢
我再往回退一下
哎我都推到mp一上去
我发现诶好像跟mp一的那个东西有个交点
好吧
那我再往下走就能回到密林的时候
诶
我这时候发现我的焦点实际上是在下面
所以这个方法大家仔细看啊
采样更复杂
但是大家会发现
我对整个screen space depth
做了一个high的这样一个hierarchy的话
其实我每一次recasting
它理论上讲你就算把整个屏幕走一遍
它的复杂度是log 2的
也就是我们以前最喜欢的叫log的复杂度
对吧
也就是说你就算是1024啊对吧
更高的分辨率
我可能十几步就走到了
如果你用uniform remarching
可能要走五六十步才能做到
而且它可以在很短的时间
你跨一个很大的距离
所以这个东西的话呢
这个方法其实很有用的
它有的地方也用了这个算法
所以这个地方的话呢
也是一个很好的一个技巧
就是大家以后在screen space里面
无论你是做a o你还是做什么东西的时候
你如果需要进行这种remarching testing的话
用hz肯定是比你那个用风的采样要好的
在这个s键里面呢
他就用了high z b的这个方法
我去做这个testing
诶
这个效率也会更高了对吧
毕竟是这个游戏引公司去写的这个算法
所以工程实战性还是真的是非常强
ok好
那这个时候呢还有一个很有意思的点
这个思想也非常有意思
就是说诶
那我现在这个我假设旁边的这个pixel对吧
我要对空间进行了几次采样
我用high的方法我求出了采样点
这个采样点我在离他很近的一个位置
我也要对进行球面采样的时候
这个采样点我能不能reuse
能不能重用诶
他发现其实如果你不考虑visibility的话
那实际上是不是就不考虑这个光
这根光线到你这儿
被那个点到你这儿被遮挡关系的话
是不是他踩到了一个小灯泡对吧
我们我们global nation
会把所有的这个空间上的物体
都可以想象成无数个灯泡嘛
它踩到了那个小灯泡
实际上也是你的小灯泡
所以说相当于帮你也做了一次采样
所以这个light其实是可以被reuse诶
这个思想其实也是非常重要的
为什么呢
因为在我们真正做碳的积压的时候
你真的不可能对于每一个采样点的位置
设那么多的人去做
那这样整个计算就会爆炸的
所以说经常我们会在相邻的空间的时候
我们把这个瑞啊
大家直接重用你
你采完了对吧
就是你往那个方向打了一个瑞
告诉我说在5米之外有一个点
在空间上的x y z位置
那我假设我认为那个点跟我之间
是没有东西遮挡的话
那那个点上的它的那个它散射
它发射出来的这个radiance的话
我也可以直接使用
但是这个曲用的话
因为我和你的角度不同吧
那我会我的强度跟你有不同对吧
因为那是一个比如漫反射
但是这个空间上那个颜色
它那个位置我可以直接用的
所以这个reuse这个思想的话
也是几乎所有的这种real time gi的话
会用的一个思路
这个思路其实我个人觉得是非常的好
而且这个思路的话呢
其实还有一种宠物速度什么的
在temporal就是在实际上其实也可以重用
所以当我们做real time ji的时候
一定要善于用这个reusing这个思路好
这个应该比较好理解吧
好那我有了这样一个东西的时候
那很简单了嘛
我就开始对吧
对于每一个方向
我就沿着这个空一路的哒哒哒
往上走去吹tracing了对吧
那么其实呢这种tron就像前面讲的
就是说它实际上相当于对这个
这个对整个光照进行了一次
那个那个那个profiling进行了一次filtering
那么其实呢我们在这个就是说
在这个就是在估算的时候
其实我们需要考虑到很多的roughness
这些东西
在前面这张图已经给大家讲过了一遍
对吧好
那其实s g i呢就是我今天讲的比较粗啊
因为我今天更多的时间给lumen
那么其实s g i
我个人认为是一个非常好的处理
这种比较偏高
oc比较偏spectre的reflection
第二个呢它的质量其实不错的
它能补充很多的细节
但是他的问题呢就是说因为我在我是spring space
就是在屏幕空间没有的东西我就看不到
比如像上面那个例子
比如说那个上面浮在空中的cube对吧
地上有个偏镜面的东西
那cube下面的底面的话应该是偏黑的
对不对
但是因为黑色的那个像素点没有
所以呢那边的反射的数据我就拿不到
其实类似的这种artifact的话呢
在这个s加里蛮多的
但是不这个
但是呢这不影响s加加
作为一个非常有用的算法
那这个s加不是有很多artifact吗
那这些artifact呢在哪儿
被基本上全部解决了呢
诶这个首先讲r c s g r s加
其实的啊是一个非常有用的方法
为什么呢
它有几个点特别的好
第一个呢它能够处理非常近的那种contact shadow
因为你想他反而在switch用high z b对吧
就是那个那个high z buffer
进行这种re remarching
其实high贼b的精度是很高的
那么所以我能够比如说两个物体的交界面
那么细腻的几个pixel的内容误差
他都他都能把你算出来
这个contact shadow他处理的很好
但是以前那个就是light william
就是那个worklife的方法呢
这一点反而处理得很糟糕
第二个呢就是它的这个hit点计算
因为用了hz b的方法去算的比较准对吧
这比你那个就是一个worko去approximate
要准的多
第三个呢就是说无论你的场景有多复杂
我不管你场景是有什么东西限制的
比如说你用了非常复杂的nana技术对吧
你这个场景里面还有什么
还有动态的物体
对不对
那对于我s j来讲
i don't care对吧
我都对我来讲就是一张带深度的对吧
带亮度的这样的一个有million的
上百万个小灯泡组成的一张图而已
剩下我所有的计算都是基于这张图来做的
所以的话呢它实际上对场景的complex
complexity是无感的
同时呢它也能够处理动态的物体
哎
这几个属性其实非常的重要的
为什么呢
因为这就是为什么
在这么复杂的len架构里面
sg还是有用的好
我讲到这儿呢
基本上把我搜集到的lumen的
一些前导的研究工作
基本上就全部讲了一遍
这个有同学在弹幕里跟我们讲
说
讲到九点半了
我们的课程主体还没有开始
对是的
这就是我们一四的风格啊
我们114其实还是蛮学术向的风格
我们以前在这个搞科研的时候
我们去理解一个算法的时候
一般都会做这个叫那个就是那个叫sway
我们会把所有相关的东西全部给它
sv一遍
这个东西为什么很重要呢
因为接下来我要讲len
len其实是一个蛮难理解的一个系统
它里面的细节之多啊
真的是惊人啊
真的非常惊人
而且我们了解到很多的背后的故事嘛
就是他们这个团队做了好几年对吧
持续不断的去在这个方向去推进
最终能够大成就是真的能变成
u e5 的当家花旦的这样一个feature
其实我们是做工程的人
我们是知道就是你做的一个技术科研
能变成一代引擎的核心feature
这个难度之大是远远超过大家的想象的
因为你要面对很多很多很复杂的case
而且很多要求都是非常苛刻的
所以的话呢就是如果没有这些前导的
这个知识的
主要作为我来讲的话
是非常难以理解
就是lumen他为什么这个地方这么干呢
ok好
那就废话不多说了
我们先回到我们今天的主角了
正菜上了鲁莽了对吧
肚子已经吃了半饱了
居然你才上我的主菜对
这就是我们风格好
再讲中文
那其实呢首先呢我弟弟用几年lumen自己啊
这个这个原作者写的这个p p t
你可以发现它的特点
第一首先黑一下real time retracing对吧
大家都会问real time reaching这么强
为什么你们还要用中文对吧
他就会说哎retracing很慢对吧
你如果想达到一个好的结果的话
第一个就是trc的话呢
很多硬件其实它是不支持的对吧
那么就算是支持的话
n卡支持的还算是勉强可以
a卡支持的其实是比较糟糕的对吧
那么我还要在那个就是说呃
主机上其实是可以支持为tring
但效果怎么样
大家也是表示堪忧
其实我自己测算一下
就是那个呃retracing的话
我当时测了一下
是应该是3070还是3080
我有点忘了
但是这个量级的差不多吧
就是我们预计下个比如四零系列的话
double一下triple一下可能也就差不多了
那么你实际上用它来去做这个j i的话呢
实际上还是比较费力的
对不对
那么但是我们在做很多的场景的时候
比如说有些你最常见的印度的场景的话
那你你要多少根ray才能得到效果
他作者他自己说诶
你需要500分ray在印度的时候
但是呢我们只能afford
就是能够只能付得起每一个pixel
1/2个人对吧
我才能够达到我们的这个
这个这个就是性能的criterion
就是性能的要求
所以说我们要研发下lumen这样的一个系统
那么第二个的话就是三林的问题
三林确实是很难的问题
其实无论是这个过去的离线的算法
对我讲过
就是我们花了十几年时间
应该是几十年时间
和这个important sa去做殊死搏斗
对吧
到现在为止的话呢
也没有特别让我们自己的满意
那么一旦到了real time
与三零数量又这么低的情况下
其实三破零的话呢
比如你这个例子里面
就是你靠近窗口的时候
你的三零结果基本是可以接受的
你可以看到虽然说他还是很noisy啊
但是你可以通过filter解决这个结果
但是呢如果你离窗子稍微远一点
那filter也救不了
你看到的就是一个一个的大色斑对吧
就是这就是你所有看所有的gi的结果啊
基本上你第一版做出来之后都是黑一块
白一块
这个特别的难受
但是这就是事实
就是就是所以说rendering
他其实真的是个非常难的一个
一个一门学科
真的这个rendering的壁垒呃其实蛮高的
对你的数学基础的要求也是非常高好
那么还有什么呢
诶我们发现就是说其实啊我们的intro lighting
其实可以在low resolution上面去这个踩出来
他的想法是什么呢
诶我在screen space放一大堆的probe
wiped的特点是什么呢
我就紧贴那些要被照好的物体表面
我去获得这个pop
就pop就是这个光照嘛
这个球星的光照
然后呢我这些spars的采样
比如16x16个pixel
我再放一个他去照亮我的几何
但以我的几何呢
我每个每个像素去设定
所以呢实际上它的高频
可以通过每一个表面上的法线的朝向啊
对吧
这些东西来产生这样的效果
最后我能产生一个非常逼真的效果
那就是我们的这个右边的结果
其实lumen它最核心的思想啊
就这么一个思想
就是说我我我不要用retracing对吧
我在什么硬件都能跑起来
第二个的话呢
我尽可能的把三林做的优化
同时呢我的我的probe
尽可能贴着我真实要付的这个表面
要要绘制的表面去放
这样的话让它的精度足够的高
能产生我这样的结果
这个就是三句话讲
len讲起来就是这样
是不是很简单
诶
这个你就被误导了
其实鲁曼里面的细节真的非常的多
那好那怎么讲len呢
我自己呢就是这个自作主张
因为其实讲lumen的这个分享还是蛮多的
但是我发现就是我自己看起来还是蛮累的
因为我看到了一大堆的算法
但是我看不出结构
所以今天当我自己在整理这个思想的时候
我把它分成了几个大的部分
分成几个阶段
我定义成飞一飞二飞三飞四
不好意思
因为时间特别仓促
我没有办法给它做一个整体的一个总结页
那我就那我就依次去讲好吧
我就讲诶
第一趴呢
它的一大堆算法解决的是个什么问题呢
解决的是说我怎么样的
在一个任意硬件上能进行一个
非常快速的retracing
为什么呢
因为你无论是用什么样的一种解压的方法
你一定要解决一个核心的问题
就是说我射出一根锐
我到底能不能交到一个物体
我交到的是谁对吧
那那这个这个retracing的话
我当然是可以用hardware releasing去做
其实roman最新的一些时间也讲了
如果你用hardwretracing
我也可以调对吧
但是呢如果你没有呢
还有一个就是阿特瑞事情太废了
我希望它更快一点
那我怎么解决呢
哎len呢
他用了一个方法
其实是大名鼎鼎的sdf
就是sign distance field
sdf这个概念很有名
我相信在同学们前面几节课都跟他讲过
对不对
就是叫空间距离场对吧
去什么意思
就是说我一个match在这
那你的距离这个我空间上的任何一个点
那么如果你在我外面
那些距离全是正的对吧
当你到我的表面的时候
这个距离变成什么呢
变成零
哎你在我里面的时候
这就是反向的找到表面的距离
那什么那就是负数
那么sdf就是这么一个简单的定义
那为什么sdf这么重要呢
其实我自己也一直在思考这个问题
我跟大家分享一下我个人的思考啊
就是说
其实sdf
在对于现代的渲染引擎来讲的话呢
很可能会成为一个基础性的数学构建
那为什么sdf它有这样的一个
就是这么吸引人呢
就我后面会讲到他有些实际应用嘛
但是其实从纯数学上来讲
它是一个就是对于空间上的形体
形状的一个对偶的表达
什么意思呢
就是大家知道在数学上啊
我可以用一种形式去表达一个
比如说形状一个或者一个一个一个属性
一个函数对吧
但这个函数呢
其实我可以把它换成另外一种形式
这两种形式之间其实是等价的
但是呢
但是你一旦把它换成一种队伍形式的
去表达的时候
它会展现出很多非常良好的数学数学属性
那我很多计算就可以开展了
哎这个讲了讲起来有点有点抽象啊
但是呢我觉得如果立志做渲染的同学
一定要这个把这句话理解透
那我跟大家解释一下
就是说过去我们对一个形体的表达
我们是用船狗对吧
去表达一个个的点线面表达
这非常好
这个好处是什么呢
它非常符合我们人的直觉
但是它的坏处是什么呢
第一它是离散的
大家想想对不对对吧
它实际上是
无论是顶点数据和它形成的空间上的
这个面的数据之间其实是没有关系的对吧
它必须要通过index buffer关联起来
那好三角形和三角形之间的连接呢
其实也是不存在的
为什么呢
因为它必须要通过顶点的
就是就共用两个相相同index的顶点
我才知道三角形两个边是连接起来的
所以大家以前在做很多match处理的时候呢
我们会写大量的叫jason jason information
就是会做很多冗余的数据
把这些点线面的连接关系全部找起来
比如说过同一个点有哪些三角形啊
过同一个边有多少三角形啊
这样的话
我在上面才能进行各种几何的处理对吧
但是sdf的话呢
它从数学上
时而是和那个表面是一个等价的一个变化
但是它的好处是什么呢
第一它是连续的呃
它吧第一个它是uniform的
第二呢它是空间上的一个厂
这个厂的好处是什么
是连续的
连续的话讲一个最近比较高大上的概念
就是它是可微的
哎你既然可危了
你就能做很多事情了对吧
所以说呢其实sdf的话呢
实际上是一个非常重要的基础
这也是我也能理解
就是为什么在这一代的就是硬件上
大家会大量的就是现代图形渲染
你们大量的使用sdf这个作为概念
我个人觉得sdf
它未来的潜力可能不止于此
我个人也会对这个问题非常的感兴趣
好了
这里的弹开一点
我太喜欢这个
把一些我的思考给大家分享了
不过还好我们的小伙伴还很不介意
大家应该是不介意的吧
ok好的
那我们就就单开一笔讲讲sdf好
那既然有了sdf之后
诶
我们就可以对空间进行表达
那最淳朴的表达是说诶
我对整个场景做一个df对吧
但是呢这样的话这个场景很大很大呀
对不对
那我就会浪费很多空间
存储这些无效的东西
所以很自然和直觉的想法就是
我对场景里的每一个mesh
我去做个sdf
当然这些max的每个max自己的sdf的话
合到一起
它又会形成我整个空间的sdf对吧
但这里面是有一套数学变化了
我今天就不展开了
那我就形形成了一个promise的
这样的话对于我的一个游戏场景来讲的话
我里面有成百上千甚至上万个对象的话
其实呢这上万个物体可能就是几百种物体
通过比如说平移旋转放缩得到的
那么这个时候呢
我只需要存着几百个物体的sdf
我加上它的位移
这个这个transform的这个数据的话
其实我就可以把场景表达出来对吧
这个就是非常自然的一个表达
但这里面有一个细节
这是我自己现在还没推完呢
就是说如果我对这个物体的放缩
不是uniform的
什么意思
就是x y z轴是等比例的放松
比如说x轴放长一点
y轴放短一点
那这个sdf方程怎么去找啊
好像是有那么一丢丢的问题对吧
这个好像呃
我现在还没想到数学上怎么变化
但是呢如果你是等比例放缩的话
那无论是这个就是平移变化还是旋转变化
还是这个放缩变化
那都是可以的
sdf可以简单的变化
也就可以直接用
ok好
那我们如果有每个mesh的sdf的话呢
哎这个时候我这里面讲个细节
就是说我们在工程实践中
如果用sdf表达一个match的时候
这也是lumen原来讲就是你特别细的
怎么办
你啊已经跨过了我最小的两个worker之间的
这个距离
因为我毕竟是对空间进行点采样嘛
那怎么办
我就把你撑开了一点
也就是说否则的话呢
你这两边的这个面啊
它的那个那个那个distance值都是正直
没有一个负值
所以我就检测不到你那个面的存在
这是sdf的一个问题
就是说对特别细的面我比较难以表达
但这个没关系
这个瑕不掩瑜
因为很多时候sf
我做的也不需要那么的精细好
一旦有了sdf之后呢
我们就会变得非常的efficient
做一些事情
比如说我们做retracing对吧
我们做marsh
那marshine呢这里面最难的一个问题是什么
就是不长对吧
我记得我从最开始讲ranging的时候
都讲到这个问题对吧
比如说讲了hz b对不对
但是如果不是screen space
在workspace里面我做个marching的话
那我怎么知道我这一步到底跨多远呢
我以前的做法只能是一步步的试对吧
我可以用object bounding去试
但是绑定去试它也是很废的
但是你如果有整个这个场景的
这个这个这个就是sdf的话
实际上你从出发点出发
你的第一个这个它的第四层的距离的话
是不是就是你最安全的第一步的距离
你就会从p0 点跳到p一点对吧
那你从p一点的话
你再去找一个
他的那个一个安全的距离对吧
他帮你
你可以找到p2 点
这样以此类推
我们可以非常快的就可以hit到物体的表面
而且大家可以思考一下这个表面啊
实际上是比较安全的
就是因为你就算步子大了一点
你穿进去了
因为sdf它是有符号的嘛对吧
你进去之后给你个负数
那个负数就告诉你说你的表面应该在哪
你还可以弹回来
所以这个retracing它是非既快又鲁棒
诶这是sdf非常多的好处
那么sdf第二个好处是什么呢
诶我假设做contracing contracing
我们举个例子
比如说我们要做soft shadow对吧
其实soft shadow本质上讲了什么呢
就是说如果天空中有一个面积光源对吧
假设这个圆形的
那我这个时候我去看他的时候
大概多少面积会被挡住
那么我现在假设求到了一个他那个点的话
实际上我军machine的时候
我根据你从那个点出发
到mash的最近的点的距离
我可以画一个画一个球
画一个圆出来对吧
那在那个点的
整个你的空的这个disc
和那个最近的距离之间的disc之间
画一大一小两个圆
这两个圆之间的比值啊
是一个非常好的approximation
就是说你离那个东西有多远
但是大家很多都会讲说这肯定非常不准啊
确实是非常的不准
但是呢它已经是非常好用的一个东西
而且这个东西的话呢
其实如果我们在做设定的时候
比如说我们在天上进行这种a lin
采样的时候
是不是sdf这时候也可以起作用对吧
所以sdf在这个时候它是非常的好用
所以最早的时候就有人想到用sdf做soft shadow
但今天来看的话
这实在是大材小用了吧
sdf这么牛逼的东西可以做很多事情好
现在有的发展的话
就是可以考虑到就是说诶我可以
如果你对一个物体做一个绑定
你生成的sdf很可能就是用采样很大对吧
那怎么办
哎我可以对它进行这个稀书画
你会发现很多的vocal它实际上都是空的
那么如果那些vocal
他的diss都会大于那个阈值的话
我们就把它全部干掉
这样的话我用一个简单的index
我就可以把这个存储啊给它减少很多
那么这样的一个东西的话呢
实际上也是一个工程上的一个时间
但确实可以有效地减少df的存储的空间
但是我个人呢一直在怎么说呢
我一直在怀疑一件事情
就是说确实你只要大于一个第四的阈值
你把那些vocal全部标为空对吧
你这样只要存那些有用的地方
有用的区域
但是的话呢它会导致你的这个remarching的
这个迭代的步长就会变长
为什么呢
因为以前我一次性
比如说我从那个天上那个角进来的时候
我一次性可以这个跳一大步
但现在的话呢我发现哎
我只能一步一步的试了对吧
但是这里面工程上肯定有办法可以解决
我们就不展开了
还可以进行l o d对吧
那我每一层的l o d实际上可以达到sdf
还有一个很有意思的属性
就是说因为它是空间上连续的可导的
它的导数呢实际上是什么呢
是它的法向诶
这个很有意思对吧
你可以用它的反向求它的梯度啊
其实就是它的法向
而这个时候呢
也就是说我们用了一个uniform的一个表达
可以表达出一个无限精度的一个mesh
我既能得到它的面积
而且又能对它进行快速的求交运算
还能够迅速的求出它连续的这个法线方向
这也是sdf很巧妙的一个点
所以呢你有了这样的这个sf
它本身因为它是uniform的
它很容易做
大家想想我们以前做mash d的时候多痛苦
对不对
有多少软件专门是把你传给mesh
面片简化对吧
大家以前听说过什么simply count啊
各种各样的中间键
但是如果你切换成s t f表达mesh的话
不好意思
他就是个当桑风铃的问题
它就是可以去表达
所以呢如果你有了这个就是说p r o d
你在用spss match的话
实际上你的存储的话呢
就是用一个简单的表达
你可以大概省掉大概多少呢
我大概40%到60的空间就可以省
掉
在硬件上还是蛮可观的对吧好
而且呢因为你l o d比如说远处的物体
你可以先用这个lol的
就是那个mp比较高的这样的一个sd f
等你到近处的时候
你切到这个比较近处的sdf
而且你如果用一些简单的
streaming的概念的话
这样也可以控制好你内存的消耗诶
这个时候是不是各种好处
你全部占上了啊
对的
masdf确实是一个非常好的一种表达
那为什么就是鲁莽
它是上来的一个数学基础
就是sdf呢
就是因为它有一个应用场景
就是说假设你没有retracing的这个harder
tracing
或者呢你有hardwretracing
但是性能太慢了
那这个时候sdf是一个非常好的real time的
这个就是recasting的一个一个基础的表达
那么其实呢这种你用那个sf promise to
去做retreating的
其实还有一个挑战是什么呢
对于单个mesh来讲
你做retreating速度很快
你可以先找到他的绑定对吧
找到绑定之后
开始从绑定直接按照s t f往里面打
但是你架不住场景的物体
数量特别特别的多对吧
那我比如说我一个人也打过去的话
我沿途所有的object我都得问一遍
这里面举的例子
就是说如果把场景分成全是物体的话
那你的计算复杂度就会越来越高
这里面就讲它是hit了多少step
你会发现越靠近这些mash的边界
上的这些这些这些像素的话
它那个step就要走的非常的远
这个时候怎么办呢
就是我我因为我要沿着那个方向
有很多的很多的瑞要去测试嘛
那一个非常简单的想法就是那好吧
既然你们都是分散了
对不对
那我现在已camera空间对吧
我把你这些这个这个s t f了
合成一个大的低精度的这个global的sdf
对不对
这就是一个场景的表达
那当然了
这里面比较复杂
第一个就是从permission sdf怎么合成
一个就是global
这里面是有一些数学变换的
那么第二个的话呢
就是说这里面假设有些物体移动了
有些物体的那个这个新的消失了
有些物体增加了
这里面你还要提供一套update的算法
在今天的课上我就不展开了
如果有兴趣的同学可以自己研究
但是你就想理解一件事
in the end
最后呢能形成一个整个场景的sf
那如果整个场景有了sdf的话
其实在这里面进行
recasting的速度就会非常快
因为它不再依赖于一个一个的物体了对吧
当然它的缺点是什么呢
因为存受制于存储空间
它不能像promise sdf那么精细
他做的一般会比较粗
所以呢在lumen里面的话呢
这两个东西都用了
就是mash sdf
global sd f都有用
但是我们在最后跟大家讲
为什么两个都有用
那么实际上当我们这样去做的时候
诶
一开始如果你每个物体做的话
你要测试多少物体
这里面这张图里面
如果灰阶是就是亮度是百分之百的话
那就意味着要200多次的物体测试对吧
但是你一旦做了global的sdf之后呢
它物体的测试数量就会极大的下降
因为可以快速的找到一些近处的点
然后再根据周边的match去做的话
他就会快很多
所以你有了这样的一个架构啊
是实际上你再去做任何一个recasting的时候
他其实就既不依赖于这个硬件的这个
这个hretreating
同时呢
它的速度又要比你直接去测那个
什么a b box啊
测那个ray和船go的焦点啊
这个要快很多很多
ok那么就是说呢其实这个global sdf呢
在实际上的预算中
它会做成一个密不
就是四层密布在camera这边
近处呢我的sd f精度高一点
远处呢我s t f精度低一点
因为大家讲过sdf是什么
它跟tt一样
他是一个非常uniform的表达
所以他又天然的去支持这个clip map对吧
所以你可以实现
比如进出50米
这个sdf密度高一点对吧
远处1百米
2百米
4百米s d f d f精度就低一点
这个完美的
就是解决了我们各种各样求教的需求
所以说这个其实大家可以看到
就是说啊
为什么我刚才前面给sdf
这个贴了那么多金呢
因为我们自己做rendering的底层研究啊
做了很久之后
你会发现其实数学表达非常的重要对吧
就是说当我还记得
我在以前学图形学的时候
学过什么叫影视曲面对吧
就是你一个形体
你怎么样用数学方程去表达它
如果你是一个影视曲面的话
你可以做很多事情了对吧
它可以无限的被精细化
无限的被求导的一堆的好处
但是如果我把这个空间变成点云啊
变成离散化的三角形的话
三角形是一个最糟糕的表达
为什么呢
它既是离散化的
同时它又是irregular
那么另外一个相应的表达是什么呢
诶就是点云对吧
就是worko的点云
我记得在之前我也讲过
就voxel base的这个表达
那vox的表达呢
它的好处是说它是uniform的
它可以进行过滤
进行filtering r进行各种处理
但是呢它的坏处是什么呢
就是它还是离散化的
所以sdf的话呢
这个属性其实我个人觉得还是比较完美的
但是sdf大家也不要高估
它并不能直接作为渲染
但是它可以很多渲染的计算
把它给这个进行这个迅速的这个优化掉
o
所以说这其实是lumen里面
它最核心的一套防思想
在用一些简单的camera base的这个l o d的思想
实际上的话呢
我们就可以快速地提供这个场景的一个表
达
这个表达的上面做retracing的效率非常的高
这样我就不依赖于hardware retracing了
好这是他的第一
不